[Music]
some member states are overwhelmed with
migrant arrivals while others have
accommodated disproportionately low
numbers in 2017 Parliament is looking to
reform the asylum registration system
and relocate refugees fairly around
Europe the Panama papers showed certain
European companies and individuals
launder money and evade taxes on a vast
scale in the spring Parliament will
propose how to tackle tax scandals
across the Union in 2015 there was a
record number of terrorist attacks in
member states 211 to combat the rising
threat a new law will criminalize how
foreign fighters travel fund and recruit
MEP s want to lift restrictions on
cross-border purchases and online
subscriptions to music film digital
books or sports for holidaymakers within
Europe it's all part of a plan to
achieve a fully digitized single market
in Europe renewables accounted for less
than thirteen percent of total energy
consumption across the Union in 2014 co2
emissions are also too high next year
Parliament will work to reduce them by
forty percent by 2030 and push industry
to use climate friendlier energy
[Music]